sarah thomas joins us now 48 hours later
sarah thomas hello hello hello we
welcome you
tell me this what is it like when dreams
come true
there's no words for it gail i mean
honestly it's just
it i couldn't say that i ever set out to
be a football official but i ended up
falling in love with it i often joke
about
i hated the officials when i was playing
and they hated me
but as you pursue this career and you
fall in love with what you're doing and
to be a part of
such a strong fraternity and they let a
little sister in and i know there's
going to be some more women following me
i read before you started the game on
sunday you said i might get a little
teary-eyed did you
i did in my hotel room did you i did
take us there saturday night
yeah so saturday night my mother had
pinned a little angel on me when i was a
freshman in college and she told me she
said
i may not be there with you um in person
but i'll be there with you in spirit
as you go through this journey of
college and so she found that angel
and she pitted on a little note and said
we're not going to be there with you in
person but we're there with you in
spirit
you pin this on your uniform somewhere
and then i listen to
rise up that song yes andre day yes
oh my just every word from the start
to the end is i have chills now and that
got me emotional because
i would do this a thousand times again
and rise up
into this over and over and that song
just had a lot of meaning and
it just kind of um choked me up sunday
morning sarah
i'm struck by the fact that in many ways
this started for you back in fifth grade
when you were the only girl on the
basketball team in pascagoula
mississippi
my mom's oldest sister jill lupton she
coached the u.s world team in 73 that
went to moscow russia
and the first female coach that ever
coached
collegiately is from mississippi dot
murphy and my aunt coached her but when
i was in fifth grade my aunt looked at
me and she goes
are you gonna play basketball and i said
they don't have a girls team she said go
out for the boys team
so i did let's talk about the actual
game so you're on the field
it's four reps total you're running up
and down the field did you always feel
confident on the field that day did you
feel ever
intimidated or unsure of your calls or
how you'd be treated by the players
listen this wasn't your first game but
it's the super bowl did it feel
differently to you
that particular day not at all gail
we look at the nfl any given sunday and
we treat it as it's our super bowl
and so this game was no different and
the crew that i had the opportunity to
work with and carl sheffer's
leading this crew and sean hockey lee
the crew i was on the entire season
um we prepare all year for this game if
we're given the opportunity to work it
so we were prepared and we were ready
hey sarah you know i i don't know if you
know this but millions of people who
watch football games at home
think they're the best referees
that's true they see everything they got
all the cameras and they know the right
calls
what's it like being on the field
knowing that that's going on in people's
homes
it's amazing the professionalism that
the nfl illustrates
on the field and off the field with
players and coaches and
it's short-lived they'll express their
passion about what what happened and
i'll go back and you know review things
and
review the whole entire game but you
know to all the fans at home
um especially as it gets later into the
game i guess they're probably seeing it
like
double vision or triple vision because
maybe they're into the adult beverages
good point everybody has a great time
and i'm just glad that there are a lot
of fans out there that support the nfl
sarah we have a selfie that your son
took with you
on the field on sunday what did it mean
for your son to see
for your daughter to see you refereeing
the super bowl
yeah both of my sons were there brady
and
ridley that was really that i was with
and then of course bailey was there
them being there i think just
gave me another sense of just calm that
they're there they're safe and
i often say being the first in any of
this
is not what i set out to do but being a
mom first is what i am to do
so having them there and to share this
with me
um it was just unbelievable
sarah why did i love the ponytail so
much yeah i just love seeing that
ponytail
gail don't you just love that blonde
ponytail i love it
you know whenever whenever gerald alston
hired me
he told me that i needed to tuck my hair
to blend in
and wear little to no makeup and i said
gerald you're crossing the line there's
a lot of things i think the good look
for and makeup's one of them
but i understand why he did that so i
wouldn't
immediately be stereotyped that i
shouldn't be out there because i'm a
woman
but as things have progressed it's not
about my hair
anymore gail of course all of us it's
great my aunt is 102 as of yesterday
and she can spot me real easily so
um it's awkward for me to see myself
with the ponytail but like i said when
gerald hired me i wore a ponytail and
i'm like
you knew i was a woman but anyway
it feels a lot better and a lot more
natural with my hair in a ponytail as
the song goes you're a whole lot of
woman sarah thomas you're a badass we
are cheering you on congratulations
thank you
thank you thank you